The Joe Rogan Experience did you see the
[__] article today
um there was a thing on the CBC and it
was talking about the word freedom and
that the word freedom is being used many
times by a far-right activists Freedom
here I'll send it to you Jamie because
this is this is so [__] what Canada
is so [__] wild right now it's such a
such a like a really crazy place there
it is why the word freedom is such a
useful rallying cry for protesters the
word has become common amongst far-right
groups so by by putting that far right
in there far right but like there's no
indication whatsoever that those
truckers in Canada Were Far Right a lot
of those are working class people that
just did not like the idea that they
were being forced to do this medical
procedure in order to keep their job and
so they label them as far right yeah
Trudeau personally labeled them as
racists and misogynists just like just
so he could disparage yeah just so like
whatever they say doesn't mean anything
yeah so this is what they're doing here
with the term Freedom which is like one
of the most basic tenets for human
rights your Liberty as a human being
your ability to express yourself your
ability to talk about things to protest
to do what you want that's what freedom
is so [__] important inherent in the
idea of a free country is the right to
protest right they go hand in hand
that's why that headline is beyond
parody but it's actually something
that's being pushed on the CBC which is
really crazy well it's just like they're
setting you up for this idea that you
requesting Freedom it's like it puts you
in the category of anti-vaxxers or
racists or far-right people it's just
these weird ways that mainstream media
has fallen into labeling people in order
to pass an agenda and pass this this to
put this narrative out there but the the
fact that they're willing to do it was
something that is so important like
Freedom like protesting yeah protesting
is fundamental to Freedom so to say that
using the word freedom is something that
protesters use you're basically this is
like protesters far right product
because you get a far left protest
protesters and that's not being talked
about like freedom is very [__] they
don't want freedom the fact that they're
saying that there's an actual article
disparaging the concept of Freedom it's
really crazy it's scary as [__] and I
never would have thought before the
pandemic that would have happened to
Canada I thought Canada was this like
really friendly cool place where they
kind of got it like Canada was kind of
better than the United States in my
opinion I would go up there I'm like
people are friendlier they're nice it's
like I would say with Canada I always
used to use this term it's 20 less
douchebags yeah because that's what it's
like and now under Trudeau it's like
it's become this very weird thing have
you seen they're they're trying to push
for a digital ID now yeah I mean that I
have a friend Anna slats she is the
founder of Redux that the
um the the website that does a lot she
covers a lot of the gender stuff because
she's just like a feminist who's on it
and she's Canadian and I asked her about
this and that there's no way I'm going
to be able to I I would butcher her
explanation but she has a really
interesting explanation for why Canada
has gone in this direction and I would I
I wish I was as smart as her and and
articulate but she I I was trying to
paraphrase it what do you mean it was it
was essentially something about the way
that Canada is found was founded so how
I wish I could remember it it's I just
don't know enough about Kansas they
don't have a First Amendment up there
first of all that's that's a giant
Factor but something about how Beach
borderline corporate it was it was
interesting I just I don't know enough
about Canada and I was reading it and I
told her what is her name Anna slats is
does she have an article about this I
told her she should write one about it
because I think it's a really important
Insight that she has and she should put
it out there because I I was like how
how because it seemed very liberal to me
so how is this what seemed like a very
liberal tolerant open Society
slipped into
what seems like totalitarianism or you
know slipping into it there's they just
seem like the entire culture is open to
being like free anti-freedom which is
strange to me I always thought of Canada
as like hey cool man well they're being
sold a pile of [__] and the pile of
[__] is you must give up your
freedom in order for others to be equal
you must give up your freedom in order
for society to function in the proper
way you must give up your freedom in
order for things to be Equitable and
inclusive and fair and it's horseshit
and it's a mind [__] it's a mind [__]
that you hear coming out of the wef and
Trudeau Echoes it and they say the right
words and use the right phrases and at
the end of the day what's happening is
you're going to lose your ability to
protest you're going to lose your
ability to express yourself you're going
to lose your ability to have your say
when when things start moving in this
general direction towards the
centralized government being able to
control various aspects of your life one
of the things that we found out during
this protest is the trucker protest was
they froze their [__] bank I know
that was nuts that is [__] nuts I
mean that is some dictator third world
Banana Republic [__] yeah and the
fact that that was going on in Canada
and they Justified it and they didn't
just freeze their their money the people
that were protesting they froze the the
bank accounts of people that were
donating yeah yeah that was the [__]
insane yeah it was really really insane
so that's what comes when you start
using terms like you know freedom and
connecting it to the far right